when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby this will continue to happen when
you continue to have a governor who will
not stand up for the people of texas his
only interest is the gun lobby
[Music]
to my republican colleagues imagine if
it happened to you
imagine if this was your kid or your
grandkid
how would you feel
could you ever forgive yourself
for not supporting a simple law that
would make these mass shootings less
likely
please please please damn it
put yourself in the shoes of these
parents for once
maybe that thought
putting yourself in the shoes of these
parents instead of in the arms of the
nra
might let you wriggle free
from the vice-like grip of the nra
everything
most governing in america happens at the
local and state level and over the past
10 years we have seen hundreds of pieces
of common sense gun legislation that
have passed in cities and states across
america now we live in a country
that of course you know has poorest
borders so we have to do a better job
of ensuring that our elected officials
have the moral courage to do what's
right and to pass legislation at the
federal level
this is you know not
a democratic issue it's not a republican
issue this is a uniquely american issue
[Music]
all i can say is that um the second
amendment is part of our constitution
and
banning a particular set of guns would
be
you know if democrats want to impose the
assault weapons ban again bring it up
let's vote
[Music]